اهلا بكم في هذه النافذه الجديده للتحليل
العسكري لمجريات حرب اسرائيل على قطاع غزه
وفيها نستضيف المحلل العسكري اللواء فايز
دويري ونتابع اخر تطورات المشهد ميدانيا
على الخريطه التفاعليه مع الزميل عبد
القادر عراضه تفضل عبد القادر شكرا ليلى
ولعلي ربما انطلق من منطقه الشمال ولكن
ذلك لا يعني بان المناطق الاخرى لم تشهد
تطورات حيث يمكن الاش شار بالاساس الى
المنطقه الوسطى نحن نتحدث عن عمليه قصف
طاله المناطق الشماليه واشتباكات في هذه
المناطق سواء ما تعلق منها بالخصوص في
جباليا وحي الشيخ رضوان في الشمال ولكن
كان هناك قصف لافت للمناطق الوسطى تحديدا
البريج سنعود لها وايضا اشتباكات
وايضا اداء للمقاومه في بالخصوص في منطقه
خان يونس في الجنوب لو ذهبنا الى
المنطقه تحديدا الى المنطقه الوسطى لعلي
ربما انطلق من هذه المنطقه وتحديدا من
مخيم البريج حيث في اخر اعلان للجيش
الاسرائيلي تحدث على انه بدا بان الفرقه
قال الفرقه رقم 36 بدات هجوما على مخيم
البريج وحينما نتحدث عن مخيم البريج نحن
نتحدث عن احد المخيمات المهمه في منطقه
الوسطى التي تعرضت خلال هذه الايام الى
عملي قصف اسرائيلي سواء من الجو او من قصف
بالدبابات لكن ايضا مخيم النصيرات وايضا
مخيم المغازي شهد قصفا ممثلا اذا هناك
عمليه استهداف واضحه لهذه المنطقه الوسطى
ولعل ما اعلنه الجيش الاسرائيلي يؤكد هذا
الاستهداف ياتي ذلك في وقت ايضا المقاومه
اعلنت عن عمليه استهداف هنا في هذه
المنطقه كتائب القسام تحدثت عن
استهداف قوه
اسرائيليه هنا شرق مخيم البريج وذلك
بقذائف بقذائف الياسين هذه القوه كانت
مشكله من ثمانيه جنود فاردت منهم قتل
وجرحه لكن كان هناك ايضا استهداف لنقله
جون دوما في شرق مخيم البريج وكان ايضا
استهداف لدباب بتين من نوع ميركافا دوما
في منطقه البريش لا نبرح هذه المنطقه دون
ان ننتقل الى منطقه اخرى وهي جحر الديك
جحر الك التي تحدثنا عنها كثيرا وكان
للمقاومه فيها العديد العديد من عمليات
الاستهداف لقوات متحصنه تحدثت المقاومه
ايضا عن استهداف عدد
من الاليات العسكريه في منطقه جحر الديك
ولكن ايضا استهداف لعدد من الجنود متحصنين
في هذه المنطقه اذا جحر ديك ايضا هي جبهه
اخرى لازالت المقاومه تبادر فيها في هذه
المناطق الوسطى لو ذهبنا الى
المنطقه الشماليه وتحديدا التطورات هنا في
جباليا جباليا تعرضت الى قصف عنيف وكان
الامر نفسه بالنسبه للمناطق الشماليه
لمدينه غزه ولكن ايضا المناطق
الشرقيه نقلت الجزيره حديث عن عمليه قصف
لاحد المنازل في مدينه غزه ووجود تقريبا
60 م 60 مفقودا في هذا المنزل من ثلاث
طوابق لحد الان اذا عمليه القصف منهجي
للمناطق الشماليه لمدينه غزه ولكن للمناطق
ايضا لمناطق الشرقيه مثل حي التفاح ذلك لا
يمنع من ان المقاومه ايضا وتحديدا كتائب
القسام اعلنت عن استهداف ناقله جون هنا في
جباليه ولكن كان هناك ايضا استهداف لاليات
عسكريه اليات عسكريه ايضا في منطقه الشيخ
رضوان اعلنتها سراي القدس ولكن ايضا كتائب
القسام وذلك بقذائف
الياسين وايضا قذائف التنوم اذا المنطقه
الثانيه او المنطقه الجديده ايضا التي
تشهد حاله اشتباك دائم هي هذه المنطقه
الشماليه وتحديدا في جباليه ومنطقه الشيخ
رضوان لو ذهبنا الى المنطقه الجنوبيه
وتحديدا في خان يونس نحن نتحدث عن تطور
لافت في هذه المنطقه وهو حديث المق قاومه
الفلسطينيه عن استمرار استمرار اشتباكات
على اكثر من صعيد ولكن بالمقابل هذه
المناطق تحديدا هذه المناطق ايضا تشهد
تطورات من خلال محاولات التوغل بشكل اكبر
للدبابات الاسرائيليه ولعلنا سنتناول هذا
الامر من خلال ما اظهرته صور اقمار صناعيه
للجزيره عن توغله لهذه الدبابات في محاوله
طبع طعا للوصول الى منطقه خان يونس
وتحديدا الى وسط مدينه خان يونس حديث عن
نحو
300 دبابه ومركبه عسكريه اسرائيليه في هذه
الجبهه الجنوبيه ربما نختم بالاشاره الى
التطور الاخر وهو الذي اصبح امرا معتادا
يوميا من خلال الرشقات الصاروخيه التي
تطلقها المقاومه على غلاف غزه ووصلت هذه
الرشقات الى غايه عسقله وهي ربما رساله
على ان المقاومه مازال بامكانها في ظل هذه
الظروف وفي اليوم الحادي والث من الحرب
بامكانها ان تصل الى هذه المواقع اذا
تطورات على اكثر من صعيد ليلى على الجبهه
الشماليه على الجبهه الجنوبيه في خانيونس
ولكن ايضا في الجبهه الوسطى وما نقله
الجيش اليوم فيما يتعلق بمخيم البريش نقاط
كثيره سنتوقف عندها عبد القادر شكرا جزيلا
لك وفقط ايضا قبل ان نبدا مع اللواء فايز
دويري نعرض هذه الصور التي كانت بثتها
كتائب القسام وقالت انها لاستهداف اليات
اسرائيليه متوغلا في منطقه الشيخ زايد
شمالي غزه
نتابع
بسم الله
[تصفيق]
الله الله اكبر الله اكبر يا اخي
[موسيقى]
تكب
ا
[موسيقى]
اذا استهداف واضح لاليات عسكريه متوغلا في
منطقه الشيخ زايد في المنطقه نف لواء فايز
في ايضا استهداف لقوه اسرائيليه راجله بثت
هذه الصور كتائب القسام ايضا ل نتابعها
[موسيقى]
اولا
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
oh
اذا اليات تستهدف ثم القوه الراجله ما
الذي يستوقفك في هذه الصور لواء فصل اولا
صعوبه المنطقه ومدى الرؤيه
المحدود الهدف الاول كان الدبابه تسير بين
الاشجار وكان
هناك اكثر من منظر لها وبالتالي زاويه
الرمايه كانت ضيقه جدا امام
الرامي
فبالتالي ملفت للنظر كيف استطاع من زاويه
الرمي الضيقه ان يصيب هذا الهدف المتحرك
هذا
يعني قمه في المهاره وقمه في الاداء
وبالتالي المنظر الثاني كان نفس الشيء
وحتى الهدف الثالث نفس الشيء لكن الملفت
في الفيديو رقم
اثنين
بالكاد كنا نشاهد قمه
الخوذه انا عديت بناء على اسهم الحمر
لانها كانت تشير كان سبعه
افراد السؤال المطروح اين كان من يراقب
هذا ومن يصور هذا وكيف تم
استدراجهم او الايحاء لهم بان هذا المكان
امنان امن لانه هو في منطقه قتال
و تم ايقاع في اكثر من كمين الان السؤال
ما هي التحضيرات الاوليه كيف استطاعوا ان
يستدرجهم اذا هذا البيت ولنفرض جدلا ليس
استدراج كان تحركا طوعيا كيف استطاعوا ان
يقرروا ان هذا البيت سيكون هو الذي سيتجه
اليه كيفما حللنا في الامر اجد ان هناك من
لانه هؤلاء الجماعه المقاتلين او الذي
اطلق النيران الصاروخ او التيبي جيل هذا
قد يكون انتظر لوقت طويل او قصير لا
نستطيع ان نحدد بناء على ظروف المعركه لكن
لابد من معلومات جمعت ارسلت الى القياده
المستوى القيادي المعني تم تحديد الهدف او
الهدف المتوقع بناء على المعلومات تم
اعداد القوه تم اختيار المكان ويجب ان
يكون نسبيا امن حتى يستطيع يطيع ان ينفذ
المهمه ويعود هذه المعطيات كلها تقول بان
اداء الاداء القتالي لا يزال متميز في
مستوياته الدنيا ولكن يمكن ان نرتقي في
هذا التوصيف حتى مستوى هيئه ركن العمليات
ولافت ايضا لواء فايز ان هذه الفيديوهات
التي تصور هذا هذه المشاهد تظهر في الوقت
الذي يتحدث فيه رئيس الاركان عن اقتراب
جيشه من تدمير حماس في شمال غزه لي ليقل
ما يقول اين هذا التصوير في منطقه ابراج
الشيخ زايد اين عمليه الاستدراج قرب
المسجد اين تقع هذه الابراج تقع في
الاطراف الشماليه لمن لا يعرف المنطقه اذا
نظرنا الى الجزء الغربي من بيت حانون من
عزبه بيت حانون وليس بيت حانون والجزء
الشرقي من بيت لاهيه يوجد شريط ضيق بعرض
تقريبا 600 متر ويمتد لعمق 2 ك متر هذه
المنطقه دخلت القوات الاسرائيليه منذ منذ
اسابيع قوات الاحتلال عفوا وليس
الاسرائيليه دخلتها قوات الاحتلال منذ
اسابيع ودمرت المنطقه ودمرت الابراج
وبالتالي يفترض ان تكون بناء على
التصريحات انها هذه منطقه امنه حدث القتل
فيها كما شاهدنا في اف لام سابقه كانت في
بيت حانون وهي ابعد الى الشمال الشرقي من
هذه المنطقه وكما يحدث في جحر الذك اذا
دعيني اقول انه لا سيطره على كيلومتر مربع
واحد من قطاع غزه دخلت القوات الان ناتي
في عجاله المنطقه الشماليه التي يقول سيطر
عليها لو هل انسحابه كان نتيجه اكمال
الهدف الذي جاء من اجله لو كان ذلك لا يست
لما اطلقت الصواريخ من الشمال على لما
اطلقت الصواريخ ولما استمر القتال و اريد
ان اسالك يعني انت من خلال خبرتك العسكريه
ما الذي
يدفع رئيس الاركان الاسرائيلي للتصريح عن
اقتراب تدمير حماس في الشمال في هذا الوقت
يعني نعرف الحرب النفسيه والمعنويه وما
الى ذلك ولكن المصداقيه العسكريه ايضا هي
على المحك يعني اعتقد تحت قاعده اكذب اكذب
اكذب حتى تصدق نفسك ويصدق يصدقك الاخرين
هذه رساله موجهه لداخل الكيان وهناك
انقسام في مجلس الحرب حول
رؤيه مستقبل هذه الحرب نتنياهو يتحدث
ساقلب كل حجر في غزه لاصل الى الرهان ولم
يطلق صراح رهينه ويقال ان هناك خلافات ما
بينه وبين وزير الدفاع وجانتس
حول يجب ان تكون الاهداف واضحه ومحدده حتى
تقسيمهم للعمليات مرحله اولى ثانيه ثالثه
من وجهه نظر عسكريه امر خطا ولكن لواء
فايز في النهايه اكذب اكذب حتى يصدقك
الاخرون بس في وجود فيديوهات مثل هذه
وايضا في وجود صور لاقمار الصناعيه تظهر
صوره مغايره جدا وقد وصلتنا صور للتو نريد
ان نستعرضها مع عبد القادر فقط اشرح لنا
ما الجديد نعم الليى ولعلنا بالاشاره الى
هذه الخريطه وهي توضح المناطق الجنوبيه
لخان يونس وفق صور للا الاقمار الصناعيه
حصلت عليها الجزيره يمكن الاشاره الى ان
هذه النقاط الزرقاء تشير الى اماكن توغل
وانتشار القوات الاسرائيليه والاليات
الاسرائيليه المختلفه سواء كانت ذبابات
الى اخره
ايه يمكن الاشاره الى انها تشير الى تاريخ
التاسع من ديسمبر باللون الازرق لكن
باللون باللون الاحمر هذه الصور هذه الصور
تشير الى عمليه التوغل التي تمت وذلك
والتقطت هذه الصور في تاريخ ال 24 من
ديسمبر وكما نلاحظ هذه هذه هذه التولات
الجديده تنتشر بالاساس في الشمال الغربي
لبني سهيله كان هناك حديث عن نحو
1225 اليه عسكريه في الشمال الغربي لبني
سهيله بل اكثر من ذلك كان هناك ايضا حديث
عن في
المناطق في المناطق الجنوبيه هنا في خزاعه
عن نحو 30 اليه عسكريه اذا تطورات لافته
باللون الاصفر وهذا ايضا امر مهم ونلاحظ
هنا باللون الاصفر هو اشاره الى عمليات
التجريف في منطقه خان يونس اذا هذه
هذه الخريطه بالاقمار الصناعيه اللون
الازرق واللون الاصفر اللون الازرق نذكر
هي صور لتوغل الذبابات والاليات العسكريه
الاسرائيليه في ال من ديسمبر بالاحمر تشير
الى تاريخ الرابعه وال من ديسمبر وب
الاصفر هي اشاره الى عمليه تجريف مما يوحي
بعمل ما تقوم به القوات الاسرائيليه في
اطار وجودها في جنوب القطاع وكان نتنياهو
تحدث على اننا سنكثف عملنا في المناطق
الجنوبيه من غزه اذا شكرا جزيلا لك عبد
القادر يعني في النهايه اللواء فايز صور
الاقمار الاصطناعيه لا تكذب فقط حتى يعني
نذكر المشاهدين اللون الازرق هي الاماكن
المتمد في ال من ديسمبر الاحمر الرا اما
الاصفر كما تشاهدون هو تجريف جديد نعم نعم
انا اطلعت على هذه الصور قبل قليل اي الان
19 من هذا الشهر كانت التموضع في تلك
المناطق في حال تكبير الصوره والتدقيق في
محتوى الصوره نجد ان الاليات التي كانت في
المناطق الملونه باللون باللون
الازرق تحركت نسبيا الى مناطق يبدو اكثر
امانا واكثر اقترابا من من المناطق من
الشمال الى الجنوب الشرق الى الغرب ومن
الشمال الشرقي الى الجنوب الغربي لكن
الامر الذي كان ملفت تغير الصوره ما بين
و24 في كثير من الصور كانت هناك مناطق
لننظر الى المربع الاحمر رقم اثنين هذا
يعكس واقع معين قبل عمليه التدمير نلاحظ
فيه بجانب الحديقه والاشجار مباني ليست
مباني كانها بيوت بلاستيكيه لزراعه الخضار
وما شابه ذلك في الصوره اللاحقه وجدنا انه
قد تم تجريفها في مناطق اخرى لاحظت من
خلال التحليل الدقيق و لهذه انه حتى بعض
المباني التقليديه الاسمنتيه لا اقول
جميعها تم ازاله بعض منها اذا تم تقريبا
تحطيم شكل الارض وهذه كذلك تم انشاء سواتر
ترابيه حول تم تموضع القوات ما هي الدلاله
وما هي المؤشرات هذه القوات هي تنتظر اذا
سمحت لي نشاهد السواتر معك نعم تفضل يعني
هذه هذه الا هذه الاشارات لاحظ هذه احد
المناطق لو تعرض الصوره ال الاخرى سنجد ان
قسم كبير من هذه المباني قد اختفى وتم
ازاله وتم ازالته هل هذه الصوره تقصدها
نعم لا انا كنت اقصد يعني الصوره في
المنطقه ال الصفراء كان فيها مباني اكثر
وكان فيها اليات اكثر قل عدد الاليات تم
تدمير بعض المباني الان هذه تعطينا مؤشر
عن طبيعه العمليه لانه هذه القوات هي
متوقفه بصوره مؤقته لماذا يعني يجب ان
تكون اقرب ما يمكن للامام لتكليفها باي
واجب في حال فشل الوحدات الاماميه او في
حاله وقوع اصابات كثيره بها فيتم اعاده
تزويدها واعاده رفع جاهزيتها القتاليه اذا
هذه هي المنطقه كيف كانت من قبل لنشاهد
وهي مجرفه هي هذه نفس المنطقه اذا لاذ هذه
المناطق المربع الاصفر المربع الاحمر لاحظ
هذا الساتر الترابي هذا لم يكن موجودا
بصوره واضحه ب كان فيه اليات اختفى بعض
الاليات منها المربع الاحمر الاخر نفس
الشيء حدث عليه بعض التغيرات
المنطقه الصفراء حدث عليها بعض التغيرات
هذه التغيرات هي كانت يعني عمليه لا اقول
كان هناك ضروره عسكريه لازاله هذه المباني
ولا لازاله هذه البيوت البلاستيكيه عمليه
انتقام ليس اكثر عمليه تدمير ممنهج يعني
من وجهه نظر عسكريه لا ترى في ذلك تقدم
للجيش الاسرائيلي من خلال هذه لا يعني هي
الان تحركت القوات في بعض الحالات عشرات
ومئات الامتار ما بين صوره وصوره تحركت في
الحدود القصفه في بعض الصور وليس في كلها
في بعضها اكثر اما في بعض الصور كانت
الحركه بحدود 100 الى 150 متر تغيير
الموقع فدمر المكان الاول ودمر المكان
الثاني اذا كانت انا اقول ان الهدف هو
التدمير وليس لانه هذه
متوقفه لسبب عسك تعبوي القوات الاماميه
مشتبك متورطه غير يعني داعيني اقول هذه
المنطقه بصوره الصوره العامه كانت هذه
الصوره العامه دعيني اشير الى نقطه اذا
نظرنا الى منطقه بني سهيله قياسا مع مدينه
غزه هذه المنطقه واسعه جدا واسعه جدا من
حيث الاتساع الجغرافي ومن حيث نطاق
المعركه في مدينه غزه كانت مناطق مبنيه
الحركه محدده هنا الحر المنطقه تعطي حريه
الحركه فتم دفع ما يقارب خمسه الويه في
هذه المنطقه عندما نتحدث حتى ليس في هذه
المنطقه
اذا ذهبنا الى منطقه مدينه ح اذا سمحت لي
قبل ان نذهب الى مدينه حمد هذا التجريف
اذا سمحت لي يعني الا يمكن ان يكون مناوره
ربما من اجل الان هناك تحقيق تقدم فيها في
هذ هذه المعركه انا اطلق عليها معركه كسر
العظم من يكسب هذه المعركه يكسب الحرب بغض
النظر عن نتيجه المناطق الشماليه لانه في
كثير من الحالات قد اربح سلسله من من
المعارك التكتيكيه واخسر معركه واحده تنسف
كل النجاحات وبراي كم يستغرق الامر حتى
يحدد من يكسب هذه قراءتي خلال اسبوعين الى
ثلاثه اسابيع كحد اقصى رغم ان ليبي يتحدث
عن اشهر ربما انا اقول خلال ثلاثه اسابيع
قراءتي ما لم تحدث متغيرات لانه لا ا اقرا
الغيب انا احلل بناء على واقع معين اقول خ
خلال ثلاثه اسابيع سيكسر ذراع القوات
الاحتلال وستخرج منها كما خرجت من الشم
بناء على ما تقرا بناء على المعطيات رغم
انه دفع بقوات كبيره جدا الى اطراف مدينه
حمد او ابراج مدينه حمد او ابراج حمد كما
يطلق عليها لانه يهدف الى اجراء عمليه
احاطه الى منطقه المواصي والى منطقه
المستوطنات التي انشات جوش قطيف لانه اذا
استطاع الوصول في هذه اللي حاطه يطمح ان
يطوق مدينه اي مدينه خانيونس لانه هذه
القوات اذا نجح في الالتفاف من الشمال قد
يسعى الى تجنب الدخول في منطقه خانيونس
نحن الحديث الان عن اطراف خانيونس قد
يندفع باتجاه الجنوب وقد يفتح ممر
الفخاريه وهي الى الجنوب من بني سهيلا
ليندفع من جنوب خان يونس ويلتقي مع قوات
القادمه من اتجاه مدينه ح بشكل سريع ربما
نعرج على معطى اليوم حصل بالنسبه لطائرات
الاباتشي المروحيه اللي امريكا قالت انها
لن تقدمها ولن تعطيها
حسب عدم ابدا من حيث انتهيت عدم التقديم
هي لي ذراع اسرائيلي لانه هناك خلفات
سياسيه حول بس ما قيمتها فعليا في هذا
الاطار نعم فقط في عجاله هي لي ذراع ولكن
سترسلها الان يوجد في اسرائيل 48 طائره
اشي الطائره تحمل 16 صاروخ هيل فاير يوجد
فيها مدفع 30 ملم يطلق 320 طلقه في
الدقيقه مداه ا 4000 متر ومعظمها خارق
الان هذه الطائرات لكن انا الغريب في
الامر طلبوا طائرات وبنفس اليوم طلبوا من
الطيارين المتقاعدين حتى عمر 55 عام ان
يلتحقوا بالخدمه هل هو تحضير لاستقبال
الطائرات ام كما اشارت بعدض المواقع
الاسرائيليه ان الطيارين اصيبوا بالارهاق
والتعب واهو يطير بمعدل اربع ساعات يوم او
ربما لم يكونوا يتوقعوا هذا الرد من
امريكا وهذا هو يعني الىي حد بايدن مستعد
ان يعني يواصل هذا الدعم في النهايه
القرار
الامريكي هناك قانون يسمح بتجاوز الكونجرس
ولا يعطي الضوء الاخضر لارسال المساعدات
لانه هذه من صلاحيات الرئيس في ظروف محدده
و تم تطبيقها على الواق س يدعو احر تقول
ان بايدن نفسه هو الذي رفض الان اذا بايدن
رفض معناته هذه كما اعود
للجم اعود للجمله الاولى لي
ذراع نتنياهو ليمثل التوجهات الامريكيه
وصلت الفكره اشكرك جزيلا اللواء فايز
الدويري